in one of the sessions like oh you
thought that was controversial what do
you see what the cover man wait till my
session
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
good morning everybody welcome to day
they - I guess kind of rough night last
night slept just under four hours the
jetlag still sleeping then but grateful
to get some sleep because we've got a
busy day ahead today so I woke up around
4:30 in the morning Paris time managed
to say good night to Nina which was
great get some work done have a shower
do some youtube Ray Dalio started follow
me on Twitter might be doing a collab
Ray Dalio is a multi billionaire
investor it's worth like 16 17 billion
dollars something like that then I got
some good work done check in with some
YouTube videos that we have coming up
and so I'm excited to that it's now 7:30
I'm going to go grab a coffee and head
to the Convention Center it's kicks off
at 8:00 I'm going to get my badge and
get ready to be there for the opening
intro hopefully grab maybe an hour to
asleep after lunch and then five o'clock
arrearage 5:30 I take the stage so
pumped about that let's do it day two
got my coffee forgot how bitter that
works papi was what's important but I'm
grateful to have still kind of coffee
here there should be good got a little
bit of time to kill before the event
starts so when I given social media into
your question
I made the wall I made the wall with my
video guys look at that so imma find my
usual networking strategy it in a really
busy area people walking by and let me
show you
sitting really busy area with people
walking by wear this shirt and you might
think it on social media start posting
and people contacting my networking
strategy works every time I love I love
this wall too they can see me on the
wall every time I post it in to fill in
there
work this is the room super-pumped going
to be here speaking the mono 8 hours at
another time it's going to be fun
they'll check it out check out the size
of this room it's legit and like it sit
right here
the room we start to fill up we're going
to go
Tom oh shoot I'm done states children
welcome in the entrances over there
Chaminda hi again
that work strategy 101 without the
public here in advance it on people come
say hi
[Applause]
first part of the being done it's a fun
that learnt on crowd snowplough to get
on I'm going to do what for coffee break
and lunch and some product sessions that
I'm not going to be you know so I'm
going to go back to the hotel try to
catch e coli extra use that power to
refresh it up over my presentation and
one or two more times together be back
here for 4:30 I'm excited one of the
guys was talking about how somebody may
there's kind of controversial or mark in
one of the sessions like oh you thought
that was controversial
what do you see what's covered man wait
till my session we're going to bring it
anyway back to the hotel
[Music]
so it's four o'clock I have to be at the
stage at 4:30 to practice to get set up
miked up all that and then at
five-thirty idolize I'm super pumped
about that did not sleep very well at
all I think a combination of the coffee
being in my system of the colony wake-up
call
hello combination of the coffee that
large Starbucks coffee plus being
worried about the alarms not going off
that one when she just worked you heard
it I set one on my phone and I set one
for the for the for the phone I was here
I'm always worried that the alarm is not
going to go off and so it prevents me
from sleeping and also just think about
the presentation and I always put a lot
of pressure on myself to do a great job
because I'm spending time you know ways
for days away pretty much three days
away when the Tuesday Wednesday three
days away still a lot of time away and
so this has to work you know not just
because I'm getting paid but I'm missing
out on other opportunities to help
people so this has to be great and so
that those combination of things made it
not a conducive to sleeping but it's
okay and I'm really trying to think of
you know anytime I complain to see the
positive side we talked well done
earlier on in this vlog so I'm really
grateful that I have a hotel room that's
right across the street from the
conference center that I can usually
come back to and grateful that I have a
nice soft bed to sleep in at least relax
in and not be forced to be out and about
losing more energy I heard a baby cry
for a little bit and so I'm really
grateful for that baby not freaking out
because I've been in hotel rooms where
the baby cries all night and that sucks
and it's pretty clean air there's a lot
of smoking in general in Paris and I get
up objective smoking so it's great that
it's so clean so that's the positive I
had a shower I changed this shirt look
at that huh special new shirt this is a
performance shirt and I'm pumped I'm
excited and ready to go speak ins I'm
going to take you guys with me all right
I'm here
it's almost Showtime we're getting set
up there it is club talents off in the
back here's the room again going to be
filled the people I'm pumped
let's call our last speaker today last
but not least he's a successful
entrepreneur on a mission to help 1
million entrepreneurs just that right
here's the offer of this absolutely
great book find your one word and is a
rockstar on YouTube with more than
700,000 subscribers ladies and gentlemen
please give a warm welcome to Evan
Carmichael
I love meaningful meters I love being in
a room for people who want to be
inspired who come to learn what improve
themselves who want to take the
knowledge that they took here and apply
to their business and most importantly I
love being with people who want to take
action because that's what we do as
leaders everybody stays up too quickly
for exercise anybody send up in the
house place up a little bit I need I
need - sighs more everybody stand up
what you put your hands up like this
remember the hands up like this there we
go all right when I got the three what
we're going to do is we return the first
dish to us we're going to give a high
ten you're going to say you're a leader
baby
there
I don't celebrate a little giant bottle
kids here at a bakery
Philemon is wrapping up lots of fun got
to make a new frame which has been great
take lot of selfie invention question
before just kind of chilling there
Network team Robinson food from
Champaign that Sheen's the mozzarella
cheese you know I'd have a little bit
Shawn for the children my trainer or
otherwise everything is going really
really well can hang out a little bit
longer and they may think of some other
activities planned
I just go where my handler tells me to
go and then I connected with nina so
super happy about that she's doing well
she wants me to bring her back something
special from Carrie so I got a I got a I
got to find something to bring home to
Nina should be food-related Nina loves
her food so I got to find something that
is not to floor but tasty so that's
going to get the challenge you guys have
well okay that's advice because when you
watch they'll be home
anyway haven't won the train is gonna
kill me for this
all right had a great dinner looks every
year and heading back to the hotel so
that restaurant that we went to was run
by a friend of his and he got some
custom stuff there at the end so
thoroughly but so amazing blew past my
calorie restriction for the day so Shawn
is not gonna be happy with me but the
rest of it was actually pretty solid so
we'll be okay okay if I go to hopefully
catch ahold Amina it's 10:30
Paris time which means it's 4:30 calm so
hopefully I'll be able to get a hold of
her connexes she's doing pack up and
ready to head back home tomorrow I have
some time
- a little bit on the town in 11 a.m. on
the flight from back home to my wife
good morning good morning good morning
that the fire are my building in morning
they had this creepy fire company London
were spread too fast and hit the poison
25 family so I'm washing on CNN and our
arm goes off my building the Riviera
gotta get out of here
it's a Stokes observer these ok here
ruthless little scary I woke up
eyetality fantastic in the first two
nights I actually had like cleaner half
four hours sleep so feels good have
holotype I didn't get to do any painting
this morning
I'm waiting for my ride the airport's
going to come in about 20 minutes itself
in right now it's gonna gradually with
the on without a comedians so I'm out
it's he where what's going on get back
to the lobby I got to get home I got to
see my wife all right everything's okay
and the breathe relax
waiting on my ride to the airport and
it's like Oh
[Music]
[Music]
when I nemeth friends and former
co-workers collect Starbucks mug in
every city but not just City T goes to
cities other people go to and so he
reminded Mina that not much in Paris I
need to pick him up
a Starbucks carrots mug and so usually
they can find you can find them at the
airport so I'm looking for Starbucks for
you Tony
I should be sitting in the Air France
lounge right now relaxing doing more but
impossible each other for the Starbucks
for you Tony but appreciate it man so
pick options you care France lounge my
health care then the options here came
about lounge in Toronto check out what I
got and some salad and tomatoes and
cheese shrimp mushrooms chicken turkey
banana going to eat this or support
plane they've got power here on the
plane which means I get more fun
videos the kind of light or heavy
working on my new
just got off got to get custom hold and
hopefully okay what and one way Jesus
emails you can sync up with schedules
otherwise can take uber really help look
around
boyfriend
defective a lot of us
okay thank you for joining me hope you
have a great weekend